david horowitz is a radical right winger
who in my mind is most notable
for once telling dave rubin in an
interview that barack obama was a
communist
and this came up during my interview
with dave rubin years ago which i'll
play for you in a little bit
now since then i've not even heard the
name david horowitz mentioned but he
resurfaced yesterday on right-wing
propaganda network
newsmax to say that the w-h-o
the world health organization is also a
communist organization
run by a quote terrorist
let's dig into it and there's there's
actually this allows me to
tell you some things about what's going
on at the who let's take a look at the
first clip
you know is this do you think part and
parcel of their whole program here you
say it's just about control is it really
just about control
the chinese communists whom the
democrats defended during the virus
who went to biden's first acts was to
give them half a billion dollars to that
uh communist organization who
the world health organization it's run
by an actual terrorist
um that's the the first thing that they
did
was to blame blame trump for
using the word china virus
we know the president has a hammer over
him because of the
criminal activities of his son nancy
pelosi has huge investments in china
she's protecting eric swalwell who not
only slept with the chinese
communist spy but allowed her to build
his
his political career he sits on the
intelligence committee
these are incredibly disturbing facts
about the democratic party and i think
we know david that if if biden's not
going to talk about hong kong and taiwan
with china those things are off the
table
this isn't going to come up in this
meeting either we'll have to leave it
there for now great to see as always
dave we're
out of time up against the commercial
break so david horowitz is now 82 years
old
and his one line is the same one as it
was when he was 72
and uh when he was 62 anyone he doesn't
like
is a communist and just about everything
that david horowitz said there
is false remember that eric swalwell
handled the chinese spy situation 100
correctly uh eric swalwell was notified
by authorities
this woman you had a relationship with
what we believe is was
is slash was a chinese spy and he
immediately
turned over all the information he had
cooperated fully
and he's not even been accused of any
wrongdoing so horowitz mentions eric
swalwell
the interview isn't even really about
eric swalwell that's just like an aside
here is david horowitz years ago saying
that barack
obama is also a communist this is just
his go-to
this is this is why i say barack obama
is a communist
he was raised by communists he's his
whole political career until he became
the united states senator
was in the communist left uh i mean i
know these people
if you are part of a movement that you
know is evil
the first thing you want to do is warn
other people about it especially when
it's so deceptive it talks about social
justice and all this crap
anyway no well i mean but he hasn't so
that's how you know what his allegiances
are
and so of course barack obama is not a
communist and
back then i actually asked dave rubin
about this
when i said to dave rubin you know
sometimes you don't push back when
people say crazy things and he said well
what's an example of that
and i cited that exact interview with
david horowitz and here's how it went
with dave rubin
now when david horowitz in this specific
instance when he said that communist
thing
i was in that particular case i was
about to stop him
but you're right he then did quickly he
like sort of said it it was right at the
top of the interview he kind of
flew right into something else and then
and then the conversation just went from
there
i do remember thinking in the interview
that i wanted to get back to it but
in the course of an hour conversation i
think that one was almost an hour and 20
minutes
uh you know sometimes something's gonna
get lost the hilarious part
is that horowitz didn't go right into
something else as dave rubin says dave
horowitz and uh david horowitz in fact
sort of like paused and dave rubin
could have asked him about well what in
what ways
is barack obama a communist it was
reuben who chose to move on so
david horowitz is known for calling
anything he doesn't like
communism and anybody he doesn't like a
communist
and interestingly nobody seems
interested in confronting david horowitz
about it now i don't know if they're
intimidated by him
or they like people being called
communists i don't know
at one point david horowitz was actually
considered by some on the right a
conservative intellectual if you can
imagine that
now to be thorough horowitz also claims
in the newsmax clip that the who
is run by a terrorist there actually is
some story to tell you about there the
who is run by
tedrost adenom tedros adenom i hope i'm
pronouncing that correctly
who's an ethiopian biologist
the allegation has been made
that ted rose when he was one of the
officials in control of the ethiopian
security services
from 2013 to 2015 um
was the the allegations range from
indifferent to all the way up to
involved in
sanctioning the killing and torturing of
ethiopians that took place
now this is an allegation that a few
people have made
some of whom have uh sort of
questionable questionable credibility
and
and um uh questionable motives as well
the allegations haven't determined
anything
i'm glad for it to be investigated but
to casually called tedros
a terrorist absent anything other than
an allegation
seems to be a bit much but they don't
care this is what they do
so david horowitz using a very common
right wing trope that that
it seems to actually pull well because
it's repeated so often by right wingers
anybody you don't like is a communist
and we saw how effective it was
leading up to the 2020 elections we saw
how frequently you would just go you
know our friend michael shore would go
to trump rallies and interview people
and they had the vocabulary they had the
language they very quickly would go to
uh biden's a communist biden's a
socialist and we know that it sticks and
maybe that's why david horowitz loves it
so much
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman